now folks instead of during a deposition
for the National Park Service and I'll
say it again
the Eagles no sure they're noble
American symbols but when it comes to
the NFL kind evils can also be traitors
the president announcing the
Philadelphia Eagles will not be visiting
the White House tomorrow to celebrate
their Super Bowl victory
due to the national anthem controversy
the Eagles who won Super Bowl 52
apparently wanted to send a smaller
group of players a handful did not plan
to attend yes and by handful she means
about 76 the only members of the Eagles
organization who did plan to attend were
two or three players the owner and the
team's beloved mascot swoop to be fair
we don't know how many people are in
swoop there could be two or three or the
entire 2017 Golden State Warriors we
don't know
even so Trump had no choice but to kick
the flag hating Eagles to the curb
saying that staying in the locker room
for the plane of our national anthem is
as disrespectful to our country as
kneeling sorry
take that Eagles even though technically
no Eagles players ever took a knee or
stayed in the locker room during the
anthem but they obviously hate America
why else would they have willingly beat
the crap out of the Patriots and
why else what we have seen so many
photos of the Eagles kneeling on Fox
yesterday
I want to show you a clip from Fox News
last night where they played Eagles
players kneeling Eagles tight end Zach
Ertz tweeted this reaction this can't be
serious
praying before games with my teammates
well before the anthem is being used for
your propaganda just sad I feel like you
guys should have been better than this
oh sorry
rule but no we're not going to be better
because in Trump country we be best sure
fact lovers wide enough about this that
Fox technically issued an apology for
taking the kneeling out of context by
taking pictures of players kneeling in
prayer before the game and using them as
evidence of protest during the anthem
you can't let a little thing like
context get in the way because without
context I can clearly see people
disrespecting our flag all over the
place look at the Pope crap it all over
Old Glory and check out the Batchelor
insulting our troops just like that and
then there's this anti-american dirtbag
boom oh look at that cocky ginger
spitting in the face of our great
nation's military I can't think of
anyone less American for more citizen
journalists Nicole Thurmond what is up
gold let's talk football
we know Trump disinvited the Eagles but
in an act of generosity he still invited
Philly fans to the White House to
celebrate the national anthem it's a
great idea right look Jordan I hate to
say this Donald Trump is a master deal
maker but this was a bad deal he said no
to a group of super bowl-winning
millionaires in suits and yes to a
thousand Philadelphia sports fans these
guys fans pulled down traffic lights
started fires and tipped over cars son
climbed in the awning of the
culture this fan hopped on top of a
police van do you have glass everywhere
cars that were set on fire authorities
roped hydraulic fluid on light poles it
didn't work but being googa happy come
on Nicole these are the common man salt
of the earth people know Jordan they're
salt the earth people
okay nothing survives them like remember
that cute little robot from 2015 who was
hitchhiking around the world he was so
excited to explore the u.s. then he went
to Philly and they beat him to death
Philly fans are lawless raging maniacs
and Trump invited them into his home the
White House which by the way is a rental
okay so so you're afraid they'll burn
down the White House no no I'm afraid
they're gonna get jobs in the White
House
listen Trump loves bruisers okay if he
sees a guy whose resume is a sock full
of batteries and a pocket full of you
that guy's gonna get a job the fan who
intentionally threw up on a little girl
hey you're the director of health and
human services
the fans who crushed the ritz-carlton
awning in charge of our infrastructure
that's their job now and how about a fan
who punched a horse and then sued the
cops whose horse he punched a man
Congrats you're the new secretary of
punching horses it's an EPA job opposers
are there any three words more exciting
than click and subscribe
yes Hillary shot Lincoln subscribe now
and find out the truth they don't want
you to know and by day I mean losers
looking for YouTube handouts without
clicking subscribe do it